entonces donde nos quedamos en el último
vídeo seguimos tratando de aproximar fx
que estoy pintando con morado con un
polinomio y en principio dijimos que
íbamos a hacer el polinomio una
constante que fuera igual a efe evaluada
en x igual a 0 verdad para que
coincidieran en ese punto en principio
podríamos pensar como si eso fuera una
aproximación de orden cero de la función
después dijimos bueno qué tal que no
sólo se intersectan en el mismo punto
pero que tienen la misma pendiente y así
fue que construyamos esta recta y bueno
ahora tú pues decir bueno ok sí ya está
bien todo eso pero qué tal si queremos
que la segunda derivada sean iguales
entonces tenemos el último término y
dimos a entender que íbamos a seguir
haciendo este proceso déjenme borro esta
parte que ya no lo vamos a utilizar
entonces tú puedes imaginarte que si
quiero que la tercera derivada coincidan
entonces hay que agregar otro término de
este lado donde yo sé que el valor de fx
de la tercera derivada
pero el perdón en x igual a cero
entonces lo voy a escribir de la
siguiente forma
efe la tercera derivada de f en 0 por x
al cubo y ahora porque hay que dividir
bueno podrías estar tentado a poner un 3
verdad siguiendo la regla anterior pero
en realidad lo que tenemos que poner es
3 por 2 es decir 6 o lo que es lo mismo
3 factorial ahora porque es eso porque
es eso bueno déjenme tomar una un
paréntesis por aquí aquí realmente lo
que hay que poner es un 6 pero bueno
vamos a ver por qué ponemos un 3
factorial digo el 2 que teníamos en
realidad es un 2 factorial verdad vamos
a recordar lo que esto es por si las
dudas 10 factoriales 10 por 9 por 8 por
7 por 6 etcétera por 2 por 1 así que
estamos multiplicando todos los números
hasta ese número por ejemplo 4 factorial
será
en 4 por 3 por 2 por 1
2 factoriales 2 por 11 factoriales 1 y
finalmente esto es algo muy raro pero
bueno solo hay que creerlo en realidad
funciona para muchas cosas pero definir
0 factorial igual a 1 puede sonar poco
intuitivo pero bueno vamos a dejarlo de
esta forma es una definición que hace
que las fórmulas sean más claras y que
funcione funcione todo lo que queremos
hacer ahora déjenme borrar todo esto
porque solo lo iba a usar de
recordatorio oops no en negro en
realidad los factoriales son un concepto
sencillo así que volviendo a lo que
estábamos haciendo yo les estaba
preguntando que porque pusimos un 6 aquí
abajo en vez de un 3 como pusimos un 2
en el otro caso bueno vamos a ver vamos
a calcular entonces la tercera derivada
es decir vamos a derivar
efe la tercera derivada de f evaluada en
0 por x cúbica sobre dos por tres vamos
a derivar esto entonces cuál es la
primera derivada de esto en realidad
efe la tercera derivada de f evaluada en
0 es una constante por lo que sólo tengo
que derivar x cúbica que es 3x cuadrada
o bien si lo ponemos todo esto es 3 por
la de tercera derivada de feng 0 por
equis cuadrada entre 2 x 3 y canceló los
tres este color se ve un poco salvaje
así que déjenme poner otro color ahora
tomamos otra segunda de otra derivada
derivamos esta expresión de acá arriba y
entonces la derivada de x cuadradas 2
por x y multiplica la tercera derivada
de f evaluada en 0 y falta dividir entre
2 que en realidad se cancela en verdad
así que como ves cada vez que estamos
derivando estamos quitando uno de los
factores del denominador así que cuando
tomemos la derivada enésima en realidad
vamos a multiplicar esta expresión en el
denominador por n factorial verdad así
que realmente lo que queremos poner es
un factor ya en el denominador espero se
entienda y qué
deberíamos ya empezar a tener un poquito
más de sentido en la cuestión de estas
de estos polinomios así que en general
si queremos seguir este proceso cómo se
va a aparecer la función
ok déjenme quitar esto nuevamente la
razón por la cual estoy hablando de esto
es porque estoy siguiendo el camino para
comprobar lo que yo pienso que es el
concepto más alucinante en las
matemáticas
y te hará amar las matemáticas o al
menos eso espero si es que bueno en
realidad algunas personas bueno ya no
quiero entrar en el aspecto espiritual
del tema así que vamos a seguir tomando
las derivadas y sumando términos les
parece así que el polinomio el polinomio
de la variable x va a ser igual a efe
evaluada en cero más la primera derivada
de f evaluada en 0 por x y ahora le
sumamos bueno en realidad hay que
dividirlo entre 1 factorial y de hecho
podemos poner que está elevado a la 1
verdad estamos hablando de esto que
circule solo que lo estamos expresando
claramente qué números estamos poniendo
por ejemplo en el primero podemos poner
un equis a la cero entre cero factorial
verdad de ahí ya ven más o menos para
que era útil ahora sumamos la segunda
derivada de f evaluada en cero por x
cuadrada entre dos factores
la tercera derivada evaluada en 0 por x
al cubo por x al cubo
entre 3 factorial y así nos seguimos
verdad así nos seguimos con esta regla y
podemos hacer esto hasta el infinito y
eso es realmente lo que vamos a hacer ya
esto es a lo que le llamo las series de
mclaren así que si quisiéramos aproximar
esto en una forma muy difícil podríamos
esencialmente tomar las derivadas
infinitamente así que vamos a definir el
polinomio de x como la serie o la suma
la serie infinita y vamos a empezar
desde cero hasta el infinito vamos a
seguirnos hasta el infinito y cuáles van
a ser los términos pues en realidad si
te fijas en la expresión anterior va a
ser la derivada enésima de f
evaluada y evaluada en 0 y multiplicamos
a x elevado a la n
x elevado a la n y luego dividimos entre
factorial
perfecto esta es la serie de mcgraw link
ahora vamos a aprender más tarde que la
serie de mclaren es un ejemplo
específico de las series de taylor es un
ejemplo específico de una serie más
general que son series de potencias así
que esto puede parecerte muy complicado
en realidad la anotación de la sigma
está expresando lo que tengo arriba y
vamos a seguirnos hasta el infinito
ahora vamos a tratar de entender mejor
cuando haga esto con una función
específica aquí es donde se va a poner
interesante verdad si es que todavía no
piensas que es interesante pero bueno
vamos a poner un caso en particular y lo
voy a hacer con fx la función más
increíble de todas bueno a mi parecer la
función más increíble de todas si yo
fuese a poner un altar o una iglesia un
rascacielos a una función sería esta y
por todos lados lo pondría en el futuro
cuando la gente la encuentre entendería
bien su misticismo
bueno ya dejémonos de eso y vamos a
encontrar la serie de mclaren de la
función a la equis así que todo lo que
tenemos que acordarnos es cómo aproximar
esto con la serie que dijimos
anteriormente así que nuestro polinomio
en realidad
toda la cuestión de la de la
convergencia de las de la serie y demás
sobrepasa el nivel de este de lo que
quiero hacer ahora así que realmente
vamos a empezar a construir el polinomio
calculando las derivadas verdad así que
la primera derivada de f quien es muy
bien que sea la x la segunda derivada de
x pues por supuesto va a ser a la x así
que ya hemos aprendido y comprobado en
otros vídeos que la derivada de ea la x
es igual a su valor en de la función a
la x de hecho cualquier derivada la
derivada enésima es ea la x así que esto
es algo increíble la tasa de cambio de
la función en cualquier punto es la tasa
de la tasa de cambio de la función que
es la tasa de la tasa de la tasa de
cambio de la función wow me gustaría era
un lugar y sólo pensar en eso pero estoy
muy ocupado haciendo vídeos en este
momento volviendo a la anterior
efe dc efe de 0 es el ala 0 y cualquier
número elevado al acero es un muy bien
ahora quién es la derivada evaluada en 0
pues es a la 0 y que esto es 1 y así
cualquier derivada la derivada enésima
evaluada en 0 va a ser uno para este
caso particular de la función a la equis
y es por eso que esto es tan interesante
y se va a poner más interesante muy bien
quitemos esto
espero que se hayan dado cuenta de que f
de 0 y todas sus derivadas en 0 son
iguales y son iguales a 1 así que ahora
podemos hacer potencias de la serie de
mclaren en el próximo vídeo nos vemos